gewaltwelle in nahost der konflikt
zwischen juden und arabern ist auch auf
den straßen immer stärker zu spüren
ärger mit der im freien folge während
immer mehr jüngere geimpft werden warten
manche ältere noch auf ihren termin
urlaubsregion ohne urlauber in
mecklenburg vorpommern dürfen in hotels
und restaurants noch nicht öffnen
während anderswo schon betrieb herrscht
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute nachrichten an diesem
donnerstag an dem die einen christi
himmelfahrt feiern andere den vatertag
norbert lehmann ist auch dabei für den
sport einen stimmenanteil von mir kein
ende in sicht in jahrzehntealten
konflikt zwischen israelis und
palästinensern um das heilige land im
gegenteil
auch heute gab es wieder tote und
verletzte
aber auch im innern israels entladen
sich wut und hass zwischen jüdischen und
arabischen israelis zunehmend auf den
straßen nach weiteren raketenattacken
der radikalislamischen hamas weitet
israel seine militäreinsatz aus man
werde die angriffe auf terrorziele im
gazastreifen fortsetzen erklärte die
regierung netanjahu in mehreren städten
ist die gewalt eskaliert dort gegen
juden und araber brutal aufeinander los
michael warum es sind verstörende bilder
der gewalt aus partie an einem vorort
von tel aviv ein aufgebrachter jüdischer
mob schlägt auf einen wehrlosen mann am
boden ein
sie halten ihn für einen araber die
umstehenden schauen einfach zu andere
schlagen die schaufenster arabischer
geschäfte ein
in akko ist es genau umgekehrt ein
gewalttätiger arabischer mob versucht
einen jüdischen autofahrer zu lynchen
aus vielen städten wie hier in lod gibt
es meldungen über zusammenstöße
arabischer und jüdischer israelis im
gegensatz zu den besetzten gebieten
lebten die bisher halbwegs friedlich
zusammen ein neues phänomen das es in
diesem ausmaß noch nicht gab
nichts rechtfertige das lynchen von
juden durch araber und nichts das
lynchen von arabern durch juden die
werden das nicht akzeptieren
unterdessen geht die kriegerische
auseinandersetzung zwischen der hamas in
gaza und israel mit großer härte weiter
die israelische luftwaffe versucht
weiter gezielt hamas führer und deren
infrastruktur auszuschalten aus gaza
wiederum fliegen die raketen zum teil im
trommelfeuer und richten vor allem im
süden israels schäden an gestern
schaltete sich der us präsident in einem
telefonat mit netanjahu ein
meine erwartung und auch meine hoffnung
sind dass dies eher früher als später
endet aber israel hat das recht sich
selbst zu verteidigen wenn tausende
raketen auf seinem territorium fliegen
doch israel hat ein
waffenstillstandsangebot der hamas
abgelehnt und bereitet nach offiziellen
angaben inzwischen alles für eine
bodenoffensive vor
aber auch das ist israel in tel aviv und
anderen städten demonstrierten jüdische
und arabische israelis gemeinsam für ein
friedliches zusammenleben für uns in tel
aviv ist michael b warum michael neu ist
ja vor allem das was da auf den straßen
in israel zwischen israelis und
arabischen passiert ist das der beginn
eines bürgerkriegs
ich glaube der begriff bürgerkrieg ist
vielleicht noch eine nummer zu groß aber
dass die kluft zwischen arabischen und
jüdischen israelis so groß ist das hat
doch viele überrascht viele haben
vielleicht darüber jahre weggesehen und
eine nachhaltige integration der
arabischen minderheit ist für viele
jahre versäumt worden
jetzt geht die eskalation erstmal weiter
für heute abend werden weitere
auseinandersetzungen gewaltsame
auseinandersetzungen erwartet und die
ersten meldung aus verschiedenen städten
liegen schon vor
die hamas hatte angeboten die kämpfe
einzustellen aber israel lehnt ab warum
die israelische regierung will sich
wahrscheinlich alle optionen offenhalten
der armee starb hat einen konkreten
operationsplan für eine bodenoffensive
vorbereitet und wird sie heute noch dem
sicherheitskabinett vorliegen
verteidigungsminister gates hat die zahl
der einzuberufenden reservisten gerade
von 7 auf 15.000 erhöht ich denke israel
wird noch ein paar tage dieser kampagne
auf jeden fall fortsetzen wollen
allein um den preis für die hamas zu
erhöhen den sie zahlen soll für den
angriff auf israel
umundum auch weiter infrastruktur der
hamas in gaza zu zerstören
ob es dann tatsächlich zu dieser
bodenoffensive kommt wird aus meiner
einschätzung maßgeblich davon abhängen
ob die usa stärker als bisher bereit
sind sich in die vermittlung des
konflikt einzumischen
vielen dank michael warum bei den corona
zahlen stabilisiert sich der trend nach
unten das robert koch institut meldet 17
1419 neuinfektionen bin 24 stunden das
sind 4534 weniger als vor einer woche
278 menschen starben in verbindung mit
coop 19
die sieben tage incidents sinkt auf
103,6 im juni soll die impf
priorisierung ja überall aufgehoben
werden einige bundesländer machen das
schon bei den hausärzten ab montag fällt
in berlin die priorisierung in den
praxen weg auch brandenburg
baden-württemberg und bayern haben das
angekündigt immer mehr sind also impf
berechtigt gleichzeitig warten in
deutschland aber noch immer viele ältere
auch risikopatienten auf einen termin
susanna santina berichtet aus dem
landkreis kassel guter coach ist sauer
als 69 jährige die gerade noch in der
priorisierung gruppe 3 und hatte sich
sofort nach der freischaltung beim im
zentrum und bei ärzten angemeldet doch
anders als ihre zum teil auch viel
jüngeren freunde bekamen sie bis heute
keinen termin
die haben sich alle ab dem 24 april erst
angemeldet und die haben alle schon ihre
termine sind teilweise schon geimpft und
ich war dann ganz verunsichert und hab
gedacht warum ich immer noch
gerade in abgelegenen ländlichen
landkreisen mit einer älteren
bevölkerungsstruktur zeigt sich dass
sich nur viele der 60 bis 69 jährigen
noch nicht geimpft sind sondern auch
einige der priorisierung gruppen 1 und 2
während bundesweit die freigabe der impf
priorisierung für juni geplant ist
nach ansicht der ständigen
impfkommission zu früh über 30 prozent
der über 60 jährigen haben bisher
überhaupt noch keine info und
dementsprechend muss man natürlich schon
betonen dass das alte alles dominierende
risikofaktor für die schwere erkrankung
auf die todesfälle in kassel melden sich
dass heute viele ältere menschen hilfe
suchend an den landkreis deswegen hat
man vor kurzem hier für sie eigene
impftermine eingerichtet und wir hatten
somit zweieinhalb tausend 3000 leuten
gerechnet es kam dann 18.000 allein aus
dem landkreis kassel sich bei uns
gemeldet haben und die arbeiten wir
jetzt tapfer ab die ständige
impfkommission fordert die ärzte auf
trotz freigabe der priorisierung bis auf
weiteres ältere und gefährdete personen
vorrangig zu impfen
gefälschte impfpässe könnten zum
dauerproblem werden befürchtet der
vorsitzende des bundes deutscher
kriminalbeamter sebastian fiedler eine
vollständige impfung bringe eben eine
reihe von vorteilen mit sich zum
beispiel bei ein- und ausreisen
härtere strafen für fälscher lehnt
justizministerin lambrecht abwehr
täuscht riskiere bereits jetzt eine
freiheitsstrafe in frankfurt am main
feiern katholiken und protestanten den
dritten ökumenischen kirchentag
normalerweise kommen mehr als
hunderttausend besucher wegen corona
findet diesmal fast alles digital statt
eröffnet wurde der kirchentag mit einem
gottesdienst an einem ungewöhnlichen ort
in die klinge berichtet
hoch oben auf einem parkdeck mit blick
auf die frankfurter skyline beginnt der
dritte ökumenische kirchentag der kt
corona gerecht ohne zuschauer
im gottesdienst auch ein mahnender
aufruf zur erneuerung der kirche
das motto des kirchentags lautet schaut
hin
kirche muss sich öffnen eine kirche muss
glaubhaft sein kirche muss da sein wo
die menschen sind gilt hier darf sich
nicht nur mit sich beschäftigen würden
einen öko tee machen
der so viele von den elementen des
kirchentages nicht hat aber digital und
dezentral die menschen erreicht und ich
denke wir werden ein starkes
ökumenisches zeichen hier aus frankfurt
sind können keine menschenmassen wie
sonst aber einzelne besucher aus der
region sind doch gekommen zum beispiel
zum tisch der verschiedene religionen
darstellen könnte gerade in dieser zeit
der krise sind die erwartungen an die
kirche groß es mussten signal von auch
von aufbruch gehen von zuversicht von
hoffnungen und auch ein signal dafür
nicht weltfremd zu sein
ich glaube dass es wichtig ist dass
kirche sich überhaupt zeigt dass kirche
sich auf den weg macht sind auch zum
beispiel schön das ist nicht einfach
ausfällt in corona zeiten sondern
versucht wird das auf allen möglichen
wegen irgendwie doch stattfinden zu
lassen statt findet der kirchentag vor
allem digital in den nächsten tagen
können die besucher von zu hause aus
rund 100 videos und live veranstaltungen
wählen
weltweit feiern heute rund 1,9
milliarden muslime das ende des
fastenmonats ramadan vielerorts wegen
krone aber nur sehr eingeschränkt auch
in deutschland kamen am morgen viele
gläubige in moscheen zum gebet zusammen
das ramadanfest ist neben dem opferfest
das wichtigste religiöse ereignis für
muslime es geht über drei tage und ist
normalerweise eine familienfeier im
großen kreis reisen in europa wird etwas
einfacher wer geimpft oder genesen ist
braucht bei der rückkehr nach
deutschland ab heute keinen test mehr
und muss auch nicht mehr in quarantäne
wenn nicht geimpft ist kann sich durch
einen negativen test
von der quarantäne befreien andere
möglichkeit urlaub im eigenen land
beliebteste region seit jahren ist
mecklenburg vorpommern
wer dorthin will muss sich aber noch
etwas gedulden
bernd mosebach
die rettungsschwimmer von warnemünde
starten wie immer pünktlich in die
saison
die zahl der badegäste allerdings ist
überschaubar ein paar eisbader aus
rostock die heute an himmelfahrt ihre
saison beenden
der vierzehnte juni stichtag für die
öffnung des urlaubslandes mecklenburg
vorpommern für alle eine woche vorher
dürfen einheimische wieder buchen die
gastronomie macht pfingstsonntag wieder
auf der fahrplan steht mit der aussage
dass wir den 14 61 öffnung nehmen um
halt ein konkretes datum auch
verbindlich nennen zu können kann ich
voll ich völlig mitnehmen dass damit ich
völlig dabei und ja jetzt gucken wir
nach vorne können die gäste endlich der
buchung anbieten mitte juni so die
prognose der landesregierung soll die
sieben tage incidents unter 50 liegen
und die impfquote so hoch sein dass der
neustart auch gelegt wir wollen wir bis
zu 50 prozent der bürgerinnen und bürger
im juni geimpft haben das wird dann auch
helfen und wichtig ist dass das
gesundheitssystem nicht mehr überfordert
wird wichtig ist dass die saison jetzt
gelingt dass die saison ohne nochmal
schließen zu müssen ohne dass wir
nochmal gäste nach hause schicken müssen
ohne dass man auch mal gastronomie
schließen müssen durchgeführt werden
kann mecklenburg vorpommern öffnet mit
augenmaß aber auch deutlich später als
viele in der tourismusbranche gehofft
hatten und nun zum fußball da hat
bundesligist hertha bsc einen guten lauf
hat ja das kann man wohl so sagen die
siebte begegnung in folge ungeschlagen
gestern abend im nachholspiel ein
knapper sieg gegen die knappen aus
schalke nach dem 2 1 in gelsenkirchen
haben die berliner als
tabellendreizehnter mit 34 punkten gute
chancen auf den klassenerhalt
nach frühem rückstand und schnell im
ausgleich in der ersten hälfte gelang
hertha in roth über den flinken radonjic
die führung jazzigen gang kam zum 2 1 in
der 74 minute der 20 jährige gebürtige
berliner ist
ein echtes eigengewächs der hertha von
trainer dabei schon in der jugend
ausgebildet berlin jetzt zwar stärker
aber in der nachspielzeit im glück einen
freistoß köpfte erst schalkes mustafi an
den pfosten der nachschuss von rahman
knallte erneut aus aluminium pal dardai
erst seit ende januar wieder cheftrainer
hat die alte dame hertha vorerst von den
abstiegsrängen weggeführt
das champions league finale zwischen
manchester city und dem fc chelsea wird
am 29 mai nicht in istanbul stattfinden
weil die britischen behörden wie ihren
vereinen wegen corona die reise in die
türkei untersagt haben hat die uefa
porto als neun endspielort festgelegt
angelique kerber ist beim tennisturnier
in rom ausgeschieden sie unterlag im
achtelfinale der lettin elina ostapenko
in drei sätzen
handball nationalspieler patrick wiencek
hat sich beim 31 29 champions league
viertelfinal hinspiel sieg des thw kiel
gegen paris st germain das wadenbein
gebrochen er wird mehrere wochen
ausfallen sein einsatz bei den
olympischen spielen könnte gefährdet
sein
doppel weltmeister florian wellbrock hat
bei der schwimm-em in budapest bronze
geholt
beim 10 kilometer freiwasser rennen lag
der 23 jährige lange in führung in der
schlussrunde aber musste er zwei
schwimmer vorbei ziehen lassen dann ein
packendes duell um platz zwei mit dem
franzosen marc antoine olivier der knapp
vor wellbrock einschlug sieger der
italiener gregorio kathrin jährigen das
was vom sport zum schluss der blick auf
das wetter am freitag im norden und
osten wechselnd bewölkt oder stark
bewölkt und etwas regen im südwesten
zunächst viel sonne am nachmittag
häufiger schauer und gewitter
höchstwerte 12 bis 19 grad
das war's für heute schön dass sie dabei
waren das heute journal mit claus kleber
heute erst spät um 23 uhr 15 uns gibt es
morgen wieder zur gewohnten zeit um 7
einen schönen feiertag noch für sie
machen sie es gut